You're right.
NOTE CONF
Big turnout today.
It's all happening.
NOTE CONF
Mm.
Lucky chess game.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, it'd just be one of us.
What do you wanna learn, Jess?
NOTE CONF
This is what I tell.
If it's a small lecture, then I just say to
NOTE CONF
the people in the audience, What do you wanna learn?
We'll do that today.
NOTE CONF
And since you're 50% of the audience, you can decide
we'll do bongo stray dogs today.
NOTE CONF
Did that come up and then go late?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Uh oh.
Excuse me.
NOTE CONF
Well, I guess we better get started.
Even though there's nobody here.
NOTE CONF
Well, there's one person here.
Hello.
NOTE CONF
How are you going?
What's that?
NOTE CONF
You've been restless.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
How are you going with 3000?
Are you up feeling up to speed, or is there
NOTE CONF
something you'd like to go over from the past?
That we can help?
NOTE CONF
That'll help get you more confidence.
No.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Then we can talk about binding and resolving in this
NOTE CONF
week's issue.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So this week, we got resolving plus Haskell.
So resolving is this chapter here resolving and binding.
NOTE CONF
We did the whole chapter today, and it's about one
particular problem that crops up Well, it's about two things.
NOTE CONF
I suppose it's the problem crops up.
But then this is our first opportunity to do some
NOTE CONF
kind of static analysis.
Um, back when we saw the the the mountain at
NOTE CONF
the start, we climbed up to the top of the
mountain and up there was where we could see our
NOTE CONF
whole programme and do interesting things.
But we haven't done interesting things up there yet.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so this is our chance to do something interesting
up there at static analysis.
NOTE CONF
There's a whole pile of things you might choose to
do.
NOTE CONF
We're doing what you would call name analysis.
Uh, we've managed to avoid doing name analysis so far,
NOTE CONF
uh, which is what we kind of would expect We'd
expect to be able to avoid name analysis as a
NOTE CONF
separate phase.
Let's go through.
NOTE CONF
Why?
But, um, we're gonna have to do it now.
NOTE CONF
Mm.
So a reminder of the journey we started with, uh,
NOTE CONF
strings that we passed into token streams.
And then we took our token streams and we turned
NOTE CONF
them into abstract syntax trees.
And that was the main thing for us.
NOTE CONF
The abstract syntax tree.
And we did our evaluation by traversing the abstract syntax
NOTE CONF
tree traversing the abstract syntax tree was how we evaluated
the the final result of an expression and evaluating the
NOTE CONF
abstract syntax tree meant executing statements and evaluating expressions.
And we're all happy.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and we built this relatively complex interpreter that's got
a environment tree on the side and then traverses the
NOTE CONF
tree.
In fact, it kind of traverses down to one of
NOTE CONF
the bottom bits and then goes back up and, um,
goes bottom up, working out each of the expressions.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so the expressions.
Because then well, let's let's expressions because they're nodes that
NOTE CONF
have values, Then the value of the expression gets replaced,
replaces the value of the node.
NOTE CONF
And when you get to statements, they do things either
by printing something to the console or doing something to
NOTE CONF
that environment that's off to the side rather than actually
having a separate value so that to avoid and by
NOTE CONF
the time you get to the end, um, the top
level is a statement so it doesn't have a value.
NOTE CONF
But some side effects have occurred, so the environment has
been set into a certain state, and some stuff has
NOTE CONF
been printed to the console and the program's done.
Uh, we do that by, uh, T, uh, tree walking
NOTE CONF
the abstract Syntex tree.
So first, let's find the the issue for this week.
NOTE CONF
Um, they start off in the text by going over
scoping rules, which you already understand.
NOTE CONF
Uh, cos you've learned exactly the scoping rules in all
your courses, but it's very explicit about how scoping works
NOTE CONF
here just so that we can be more precise in
our language.
NOTE CONF
Variable usage refers to the preceding declaration with the same
name in the innermost scope that encloses the expression where
NOTE CONF
the variable is used.
And then we treat it just pulls that apart a
NOTE CONF
little bit, but this is what you all understand.
Uh, this is scoping as you expect it.
NOTE CONF
Now, the one new thing in locks Well, newish for
you guys, is these these blocks just existing by themselves.
NOTE CONF
So we talked about why that's a nice language design
thing, and in fact, your languages have had blocks by
NOTE CONF
themselves, probably the whole time without you thinking about it.
Java has something at the top called a static block
NOTE CONF
that probably none of you have ever used, but it
uses the exact same syntax here of just opening a
NOTE CONF
curly brace and then closing it, Um, we start to
see even more.
NOTE CONF
We see even more of the payoff here because the
the ability to think of blocks as a top level
NOTE CONF
concept instead of having to wait until we've introduced a
four loop or an if statement or something makes it
NOTE CONF
easier for us to demonstrate this situation.
But the same thing applies.
NOTE CONF
If you've got to use an if or a loop
or something to introduce a block, we just don't have
NOTE CONF
to in our language in locks.
So this is not surprising to you, right?
NOTE CONF
A Here is talking about this A because it's gotta
be preceding it in the text, whereas this a I
NOTE CONF
was talking about this A because now the environment has
changed, and we've seen that in our own execution at
NOTE CONF
this line we've create, we create a sub environment.
But there's nothing in it.
NOTE CONF
And then at this line, we add into the sub
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, At this line, we add into the sub environment
a new variable.
NOTE CONF
Um, and so now there's something in that environment so
the environments can change during a blocks, uh, execution.
NOTE CONF
And in fact, that's entirely expected, right?
The whole point of execution is that it changes something,
NOTE CONF
and the only two things we change are what appears
on the user screen and what's in the environment by
NOTE CONF
now.
Hopefully, we can get that.
NOTE CONF
We talked earlier about statements being side effects and expressions
evaluating to values.
NOTE CONF
But exactly what a side effect was maybe wasn't clear.
Well, in locks in the system we have now, there's
NOTE CONF
exactly two side effects.
One side effect is printing to the screen.
NOTE CONF
One side effect is adjusting the environment.
And so these are things that are off to the
NOTE CONF
side of the abstract syntax tree, hence called side effects.
So you saw that in last week's diagram.
NOTE CONF
When we drew it, we drew the abstract syntax tree,
and then we, separately over to the side, drew the
NOTE CONF
environment.
There was just one environment.
NOTE CONF
Well, sometimes it it became a tree of environments.
But there was just one tree of environments, and each
NOTE CONF
of the statements that ran were making adjustments into that
tree of environments.
NOTE CONF
We those were side effects.
OK, let's get that silenced and silence everything.
NOTE CONF
So now we got the, uh, newcomers.
Are there any I'm happy just to keep going with
NOTE CONF
the lecture.
But if there's something you'd like to go over that
NOTE CONF
might help set the foundations for this lecture, anything that's
confusing you that you'd like to cover before we get
NOTE CONF
going.
Well, we'll just get going, OK, I think we're good
NOTE CONF
to get going.
Double check online just quickly.
NOTE CONF
Exam two is identical to exam one in regards to
attempts and all things across both exams.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Right.
NOTE CONF
That's true.
Exam two is identical to exam one.
NOTE CONF
The only difference is that you're not selecting your slot
for the distinction exam.
NOTE CONF
Uh, there's been one allocated by central exams and there
will be a practise exam coming out quite soon.
NOTE CONF
It's I would have preferred to have it out at
the start of this week, but it won't be.
NOTE CONF
Um you get multiple choices at the past exam.
You get the whole week to do the past exam.
NOTE CONF
But, uh, by Friday, you should see the practise exam
out.
NOTE CONF
And then Monday the past exam becomes available.
And then either friday or Sunday, the past exam becomes
NOTE CONF
unavailable.
And then you choose whether you want to sit your
NOTE CONF
distinction exam or not.
OK, so they talked about innermost and proceeding and that
NOTE CONF
that matters, right?
So if I print a before the inner versus print
NOTE CONF
A after the inner I get different answer.
You're all going.
NOTE CONF
Duh, obviously.
But we do have to be precise because we now
NOTE CONF
we're gonna hit this example where things go funny.
Now, this example is two things that are required to
NOTE CONF
make it go funny.
One is the the nested scope that just comes from
NOTE CONF
using the block there.
But the other is the inner function.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So you don't have this problem if you don't
have inner functions, But we do.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, let's look at it.
So this code sets a global variable to a and
NOTE CONF
creates a new scope, then creates a whole new scope
for an inner function and has a print a inside
NOTE CONF
there.
Then it runs the show a function, and then it
NOTE CONF
creates an inner A that shadows the other a called
block and then runs show a So what should the
NOTE CONF
output of this programme be?
Mhm global block?
NOTE CONF
Well, that's what the output will be, But that's not
what the output should be.
NOTE CONF
But that's OK.
So this is actually key.
NOTE CONF
You're getting at a point, right?
You've not seen you've not done closures before, so you
NOTE CONF
never have to think about this question.
But if we think about our scoping question, our scoping
NOTE CONF
rules, if you say the scoping rules are, um the
this variable when I use a variable a The Associated
NOTE CONF
Declaration is the one that precedes it in the innermost
um, scope.
NOTE CONF
Then no matter what print A should be talking about
this global A because at this line of the code
NOTE CONF
we've got Well, let's draw the scopes we've got Now
there's gonna be a again lots of drawing in today
NOTE CONF
so nobody ever stops and goes, I don't understand your
drawing.
NOTE CONF
But surely this week my drawing will confuse you.
So please do stop and say, Hey, your drawings confusing
NOTE CONF
me.
Um, we've got a global scope.
NOTE CONF
Uh, What I'm drawing is what we get by the
time we get to the the print A line.
NOTE CONF
But well, maybe, Let's just do it line by line.
OK, so line one and number them just to help.
NOTE CONF
One, two, three, four, 56789.
So I'm not gonna create the abstract syntax tree yet.
NOTE CONF
We'll just do this as the old school programmers line
one at the before line one.
NOTE CONF
We've got this global scope after line one.
We've got a oops, a pointing to clip and then
NOTE CONF
we jump at line two.
So before line two, we've got this after Line two.
NOTE CONF
We've got a whole new scope that has that one
as its parent.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so before line three, we got that after line
three.
NOTE CONF
Well, we don't really treat line three by itself.
We treat line 34 and five together as a single
NOTE CONF
function declaration, don't we?
So maybe let's think about before Line three and after
NOTE CONF
Line five Cos we're only thinking about the the scope
here.
NOTE CONF
Well, no.
OK, let's go.
NOTE CONF
No, before line three.
We've got that after line three.
NOTE CONF
We've got another scope that's been introduced cos we're inside
the the show.
NOTE CONF
A function?
Yeah, OK, so at the point of Line four, this
NOTE CONF
is what we see, Which means at the point of
Line four when I say, Hey, what's the A?
NOTE CONF
Then it's gonna look in its in emo scope and
say no A's, so I'll try the next scope.
NOTE CONF
No A's.
So I'll try this scope.
NOTE CONF
It's that one.
So Line four always should be that one.
NOTE CONF
And we say always, because the scoping as we know
it needs to be static.
NOTE CONF
It needs to be something you can determine at compile
time.
NOTE CONF
You shouldn't have to run the programme to determine which
variable you're talking about.
NOTE CONF
There were and still are languages that have dynamic scoping
where they say, uh even to the programmer, they say,
NOTE CONF
Hey, you don't which variable you're talking about is completely
dependent on what other functions have run beforehand.
NOTE CONF
They can bring new variables into existence and make them
go away, and people hate it.
NOTE CONF
It's just a bad way to programme, so it went
away very, very quickly.
NOTE CONF
So when we call show A down at Line six,
we're expecting show A to run and we're expecting it
NOTE CONF
to use the global A.
And when we call show a online eight, we're expecting
NOTE CONF
show and we're still expecting it to use the global
A And that's all we were aiming for.
NOTE CONF
When we do our closures.
Sorry, I should turn it sideways.
NOTE CONF
That's what we were aiming for.
When we did our closures, we were aiming for the
NOTE CONF
the function here.
We were aiming to create a scope that included any
NOTE CONF
local variables that had to come in because of the
parameters.
NOTE CONF
And we were expecting it to close over any global
variables, uh, or any variables in outer scopes so that
NOTE CONF
they could come along with us.
We certainly didn't expect, uh, this line down here to
NOTE CONF
have any effect on what was going on, although you
traced it in your head and realised that that line
NOTE CONF
will run.
So that'll change the local variable.
NOTE CONF
And so that's what we'll get.
Um, it's just not what we'd actually want from a
NOTE CONF
programmer point of view.
So let's let's trace exactly how we do get that
NOTE CONF
problem for that situation.
Get rid of my green.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we made it to line four and we've
looked up a.
NOTE CONF
I really wish I had an eraser on the back
of this.
NOTE CONF
It shows me with bananas.
Um, we've looked up, we got to line four and
NOTE CONF
we've looked up a and discovered it was the global
A Sure.
NOTE CONF
OK, now we go to line six So one reason
I wanted to say that we want we jump over
NOTE CONF
um function is because we kind of don't bring the
scope into existence just during the Function Declaration Function Declaration
NOTE CONF
is just setting things up.
Um, we really only bring the scope into existence when
NOTE CONF
we call the function.
Um, but I was setting up what the programmer's expectation
NOTE CONF
was.
So here it is.
NOTE CONF
So maybe a better way to look at it is
that executing Line three is more like setting up that
NOTE CONF
locks callable object that we were creating.
Oops, it's an object.
NOTE CONF
So it's a circle.
The locks callable object, and we're saying the locks callable
NOTE CONF
object gets its own.
It'll have a scope.
NOTE CONF
We'll have to replicate that scope.
But when we do, it's parent.
NOTE CONF
Is this one here?
That sounds a bit nicer.
NOTE CONF
So when we call, uh, show A let's do that.
We replicate that scope and make the parent that one,
NOTE CONF
and then we run the body function show a print
A so line four, and it goes looking for the
NOTE CONF
global A and it happily prints global.
And then when that function is finished, executing that scope
NOTE CONF
is gone we just leave it there to see that
it was left over.
NOTE CONF
But it's not really in the system anymore and line
seven runs and line seven goes to the current scope
NOTE CONF
and creates a brand new variable A and makes a
point to block.
NOTE CONF
Thanks.
Um, you can probably see the problem now, even though
NOTE CONF
when we call Show A.
We create yet another scope down here because show a
NOTE CONF
means, um, yeah, instead seeing one of these lock collar
balls and making a new scope that points back to
NOTE CONF
the parrot.
So we do that.
NOTE CONF
And then in show A, we run that to line
34 and five.
NOTE CONF
When we get to line four, we ask, What's A.
It looks up in its inner scope, finds nothing goes
NOTE CONF
to the next scope up, finds a and so it
prints out block.
NOTE CONF
All right, so we're happy.
That's why we get that behaviour May.
NOTE CONF
Are we happy?
That's what not the behaviour we want via our scoping
NOTE CONF
rules.
So as language designers we get two choices.
NOTE CONF
We can change our scoping rules to match our implementation,
or we can change our implementation to match our scoping
NOTE CONF
rules and we're much better off changing our implementation to
match our scoping rules if we actually want sane programmers
NOTE CONF
who can use our language because dynamic scoping is a
nightmare in this little example.
NOTE CONF
Maybe you're fine.
I can trace it, but there's no there's no reason
NOTE CONF
why show a shouldn't be in a module somewhere else,
and they will never get any idea that its variable
NOTE CONF
is gonna be changed from underneath it.
Um, and you have no idea what show a does
NOTE CONF
inside what variables it's accessing.
So you create a new variable and stick it in
NOTE CONF
your scope.
And all of a sudden, some function you're calling stops
NOTE CONF
working the way you're expecting it to cos it's using
a variable you didn't know it was using.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, so we're getting a little bit of dynamic scoping
when we didn't want it because of the way our
NOTE CONF
closures are working.
OK, so let's run through the little diagrams that he's
NOTE CONF
just using to help describe this.
I think it's very similar to mine, Uh, and this
NOTE CONF
is key, which I was saying right from the start.
In our interpreter, environments are dynamic manifestations.
NOTE CONF
The whole point of a side effect is that it
can change something in the environment.
NOTE CONF
The fact that a variable can change its value is
the whole point of programming.
NOTE CONF
So if value variables aren't changing values, nothing of interest
is happening.
NOTE CONF
So we need something dynamic inside a static structure.
But somehow a bit of the dynamism has snuck into
NOTE CONF
a place we didn't want to.
And just to be clear, I'm just gonna draw the
NOTE CONF
diagram that I've had in my head the entire time
I was talking about this, Um a an executing programme
NOTE CONF
in locks and in most languages is an abstract syntax
tree.
NOTE CONF
It's all right, thank you.
Is some abstracts in tax three plus So some interface
NOTE CONF
with the user that's my console, plus some environment.
Yeah, and these two things can change.
NOTE CONF
That's a delta for change.
And that's the whole point of a programme.
NOTE CONF
And the main point of the programme is this one.
The user sees this one change, but in the process
NOTE CONF
of getting there, this one changes as well.
But the a ST just sits there being the same
NOTE CONF
the whole time.
We just go up and down the a ST doing
NOTE CONF
controversial and every now and then just flinging something across
to change one of these continuing to traverse.
NOTE CONF
Oh, gotta change that one continuing across.
Oh, gotta look up that one.
NOTE CONF
Change that one.
Da da da.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So he's showing us a diagram of the environments here.
NOTE CONF
Any more questions?
Uh, the next exam has every week's content in it.
NOTE CONF
There's no new content in week 13, so don't worry
about that.
NOTE CONF
So Week 12, this is our last week of new
content, and so any of this could be in the
NOTE CONF
exam.
So at the start, we get this global context that's
NOTE CONF
just got the A pointing to global.
Then we create the blocks the block context.
NOTE CONF
Now he's actually done something I didn't do, which I
should have remember that every function definition puts something in
NOTE CONF
the environment for that identifier show.
A is an identifier that points to a function definition.
NOTE CONF
That was the big deal out of last week's lecture.
So he's drawn that better get this if I'm going
NOTE CONF
walking, OK, so show A has been added to the
block, uh, scope environment, and it's pointing off to this
NOTE CONF
locks function and the locks function knows about the closure
it was defined in or it knows about the environment
NOTE CONF
it was defined in and it caused that its closure.
So it points back to the environment it was defined
NOTE CONF
in OK, and then when we call show A I've
been watching baseball, So every time I say show A
NOTE CONF
I think of shoe, who's one of the baseball players
going around at the moment, None of you know cos
NOTE CONF
you don't get about baseball, but in my head I'm
saying Otani, after every time I say show a um
NOTE CONF
OK, so that was our diagram ready to go Then
we called Chalet, Um and that this was that.
NOTE CONF
This is the expanded version of what that one up
there was for the block, right?
NOTE CONF
You just added the the function bit to the right.
Then a new actual environment has been added cos that
NOTE CONF
one up there is not environment that one up there
is the object reader of and it's an empty environment.
NOTE CONF
And so in that environment I had nothing.
But he's got the show where he's showing to that
NOTE CONF
and the further one up He's got the global OK,
so sh in this in in that environment at the
NOTE CONF
top there, when show a runs and it does its
print A, it gets its global.
NOTE CONF
But then after the next line runs and we do
the redefine, we get this situation where we have an
NOTE CONF
environment with the global and the show A and now
there's a new one in the block.
NOTE CONF
It's exactly what I did, but I'm just showing you
the different diagram.
NOTE CONF
I wanna make sure everyone understands exactly what's going on.
So again, the show a call comes, which means a
NOTE CONF
brand new environment gets added to the stack.
Um, but now there's something in the way, so we're
NOTE CONF
gonna get a different look.
OK, so the point here is that, um oh, something's
NOTE CONF
gone wrong and we want to think a little bit
about what's gone wrong so we can think about the
NOTE CONF
answer.
We could just go, you know, whatever.
NOTE CONF
He's got an answer.
I'll follow his answer.
NOTE CONF
Happy Happy Days.
Um, but as you'll hopefully discover in the workshop, there's
NOTE CONF
more than one answer to this.
So understanding what's caused the problem would be useful so
NOTE CONF
that we can understand which of the possible solutions might
be best this little This little code snippet shows it
NOTE CONF
nicely.
Um, when we when we built that system where we
NOTE CONF
said when I define my locks callable, I I grab
hold of the environment that it's in and that will
NOTE CONF
be my closure safely, happily be my closure assumed underneath
that the variables inside a closure might change their values.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Inside the environment might change their ch change their values,
NOTE CONF
but they are They're not gonna change the actual set
of variables in there.
NOTE CONF
But as we can see here, you can definitely change
the set of variables in an environment just by defining
NOTE CONF
things a bit further down than at the top.
We were kind of assuming that all the variables are
NOTE CONF
defined at the top, which is what we almost always
see.
NOTE CONF
But it's not necessary.
So this should just tell you one possible solution that
NOTE CONF
one po that some languages do use.
The main languages I'm thinking of are the pascal based
NOTE CONF
languages.
So that's Pascal Delphi.
NOTE CONF
Um, Oberon.
You've never heard any of those, but they that exist.
NOTE CONF
Can anyone tell me what one solution might be?
Yeah, in case I per minute right through the V,
NOTE CONF
defining them at run time.
Well, there's lots of solutions, but thank you for suggesting
NOTE CONF
that I don't.
That's not the one I'm thinking of right now.
NOTE CONF
What I'm thinking right around one right now, Which Pascal,
Delphi and, um, Oberon do is force all of the
NOTE CONF
variable declarations to be at the top.
And there's actually another language that does something very stupid
NOTE CONF
version of this.
I think you all know very well JavaScript, which does
NOTE CONF
what it calls variable hoisting where javascript says I don't
care where you put it in the line.
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna pretend you put it at the top.
I'm gonna hoist every variable declaration up to the top.
NOTE CONF
And maybe you should see exactly why Javascript will choose
to do that.
NOTE CONF
Because JavaScript is a hacked up version of a language
that has, um, inner functions, functions inside functions, first class
NOTE CONF
function.
And so what's the shortest path to making this work
NOTE CONF
you?
Just as soon as you realise the problem, you make
NOTE CONF
it go away with hoisting.
OK, now, I said hoisting was incredibly stupid, but in
NOTE CONF
fact, it's one of the I mean, you're not gonna
get many language designers to go.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, hoisting is a great idea.
But you're also not gonna find many JavaScript programmers who've
NOTE CONF
ever had a problem with it.
Yeah, all right.
NOTE CONF
Makes some good.
Divided in a nested setting.
NOTE CONF
It just hoists back up to the next scope.
Yeah, so its scope.
NOTE CONF
But it's just forcing the rule that I just suggested.
Well, it's not forcing.
NOTE CONF
Other languages will just say if you put a variable
declaration, then some other ex statement and then another verbal
NOTE CONF
declaration, they'll just compile time and go.
No verbal declarations have to be at the top, and
NOTE CONF
you go, Oh, OK.
And you move it, JavaScript goes, I'll take it.
NOTE CONF
But I'll pretend you wrote it at the top.
Yeah, all right.
NOTE CONF
We're not gonna do that one, because that doesn't require
anything interesting.
NOTE CONF
OK, so he talks here about another possibility.
Um, and the language he uses around it now he's
NOTE CONF
got his language.
I'll use mine just to be different.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I'm gonna call this copy on, right.
It's not quite copy and write, uh, or it is.
NOTE CONF
So let's think about, uh, an environment.
All right.
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna look at this one in the middle.
That's got the arrow to it.
NOTE CONF
So this environment here has got two things in it.
And I decided that if the key already existed and
NOTE CONF
I was just updating the key, then that's fine, right?
But if I'm adding a new key, that's the thing
NOTE CONF
that breaks what's going on at run time.
So maybe I should change the behaviour of adding a
NOTE CONF
new key.
But leave the behaviour of of adjusting a key the
NOTE CONF
same.
And what he's suggesting is that with this persistent data
NOTE CONF
structure thing, is he saying, If I got an environment
and I just change the key inside, then fine, I'll
NOTE CONF
just change it in place.
But if I'm gonna add a new key, I won't
NOTE CONF
allow myself to do that.
I'll have to create a whole new environment every time
NOTE CONF
I add a new key that looks just like the
old one but is in fact just one stop down
NOTE CONF
on the chain.
OK, maybe that'll solve my problem and it does, and
NOTE CONF
we'll see why.
It's not what he ends up doing, but so that's
NOTE CONF
what this environment this diagram is showing here.
He's saying, Look, we had this environment, the block environment
NOTE CONF
had a show, a in it and maybe show a
points to a function.
NOTE CONF
Now maybe it points to a something else later, Whatever.
That's how environments work.
NOTE CONF
But when I get to the line that declares the
new A, instead of inserting that into this environment, I'm
NOTE CONF
gonna force that to create a clone of the environment
that's got the other one is the parent, and that's
NOTE CONF
this over here.
The reason that works as a solution is that it
NOTE CONF
isolates that block from the one that the closure was
pointing at.
NOTE CONF
Yep, so the closure was pointing at the block before
the A declaration.
NOTE CONF
We don't want the closure to point at the environment
after the A declaration.
NOTE CONF
And so by forcing the one after the A declaration
to be kind of spawned off the original, it just
NOTE CONF
puts it in a different part of the tree, and
we're safe now.
NOTE CONF
The code will work the way we want it to
work, so at least these two options than any others
NOTE CONF
you can think of.
And I thought of another one that's equivalent to this.
NOTE CONF
But I'll leave that to you to think about um,
yourselves, uh, you're encouraged to implement or try out, or
NOTE CONF
at least trace through the consequences of in the interpreter
in your workshop this week.
NOTE CONF
Because we don't do those two.
We go on and do another one.
NOTE CONF
OK, so why do we do another one?
Uh, a couple of reasons.
NOTE CONF
First is, uh, this way is fairly common in real
life.
NOTE CONF
Second, it allows us to try out a semantic analysis
phase and forces us to exercise our tree traversal muscles
NOTE CONF
forces us to write another visitor.
Separate visitor.
NOTE CONF
We got two so far, we got the a ST
printer, which we kind of forgot about and stopped doing.
NOTE CONF
We've got the interpreter, which we've been doing the whole
time.
NOTE CONF
This is a chance for us to make a third
one.
NOTE CONF
Uh, which is semantic analysis.
And every semantic analysis you do ends up being a
NOTE CONF
tree traversal.
And all the fun that comes later is in semantic
NOTE CONF
analysis.
So this is better from a learning point of view.
NOTE CONF
But as I say, it is actually what, uh, most
languages would choose to do internally, partly because they're already
NOTE CONF
doing lots of semantic analysis, so they can just bolt
this on as another semantic analysis phase.
NOTE CONF
Semantic analysis is a cheap idea.
You know, programming language designers are already thinking in terms
NOTE CONF
of semantic analysis.
OK, so what is semantic analysis?
NOTE CONF
Well, you've done it.
You do it.
NOTE CONF
Your Java programme does it all the time.
Uh, what are different types of semantic analysis you can
NOTE CONF
think of?
So semantic means the meaning of the programme rather than
NOTE CONF
the text of the programme.
And you know what analysis means and what kind of
NOTE CONF
things can you think that your compiler does?
If you would count as semantic analysis, it's like the
NOTE CONF
surgery variable not being used.
Yes, that's a semantic analysis.
NOTE CONF
So you often Java probably doesn't tell you that, but
some languages do.
NOTE CONF
Python's always telling me variables aren't being used.
Um, but there's no reason Java couldn't, I suppose.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
It's one, uh, lets just the verb is used out
NOTE CONF
of scope.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
And that will go under the name analysis that we're
NOTE CONF
about to do now.
This analysis would capture that one.
NOTE CONF
Another one is type analysis.
Are you using a variable in the place that that's
NOTE CONF
supposed to be used and what else can I think
of for Java?
NOTE CONF
Uh, try catch blocks.
Have you got a throw that's not being caught?
NOTE CONF
That's being done by semantic analysis.
Yeah, that'll do.
NOTE CONF
So.
Name analysis, type, analysis.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and some What?
Well, let's call that execution.
NOTE CONF
Uh, that, uh, that, uh, exception one we'll call that
control flow analysis.
NOTE CONF
Uh, those three happen all the time, and we're gonna
do the name analysis.
NOTE CONF
OK, so what am I gonna I wanna I wanna
draw a diagram, but I wanna make sure I get
NOTE CONF
it just right.
Hm.
NOTE CONF
Just scanning to make sure.
OK, let's just get into it.
NOTE CONF
And then I'll draw a diagram.
I just wanna make if I draw a diagram and
NOTE CONF
explain all that and then find out it's slightly different
to what he does.
NOTE CONF
That's not so good, because he's calling it a variable
resolution pass.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna call it a name analysis pass just because
I'm used to doing that.
NOTE CONF
Um, now there's a a bit of time and effort
is spent comparing this to a interpreter because that's the
NOTE CONF
only other kind of tree path we've got.
But it's actually un.
NOTE CONF
It's almost unusual to have the interpreter as a tree
pass.
NOTE CONF
It's much more normal to have syn semantic analysis as
a tree pass.
NOTE CONF
Um, but interpreters, as opposed to compilers, do tend to
use a tree pass for the interpreting compilers will use
NOTE CONF
a tree pass to spit out the target source code
and then all the executions done on the target source
NOTE CONF
code.
Uh, but it makes a bit of a point there.
NOTE CONF
There's no side effects, there's no control flow.
Um, the point being that the interpreter was doing a
NOTE CONF
couple of things that we don't do in sta static
analysis, the main one being, you know, looping around all
NOTE CONF
the loops, choosing which of the if branches to go
down.
NOTE CONF
Um, why would a semantic analysis not do those?
They sound like useful things.
NOTE CONF
Uh, they're not time bounded, so semantic analysis should happen
quickly so that it can give feedback to the programmer
NOTE CONF
without having to run the programme.
If I had to run the programme to find the
NOTE CONF
error, I might as well just run the programme.
So these are all things that we can do faster
NOTE CONF
than running the programme, and that means you've got to
avoid any of the possible recursive parts of a programme
NOTE CONF
or any of the possible infinite parts of a programme
or long parts of a programme.
NOTE CONF
And you've got to make sure your semantic analysis is
actually just, you know, one visit for one node.
NOTE CONF
OK?
So if statements they might feel like, uh, visiting each
NOTE CONF
node is a cost.
But to choose which node to visit, you've got to
NOTE CONF
do a bunch more visits.
So just think of it as the you want to
NOTE CONF
do a fast version one visit one node.
You've gotta make your decision just by visiting the node
NOTE CONF
once, which means when you get to a loop, you
can't visit over and over again.
NOTE CONF
When you get to a function, you can't call over
and over again and put everything in the trees.
NOTE CONF
Gotta be visited just once to make the answer, to
decide the answer.
NOTE CONF
So it starts off by making a resolver class and
this is just another visitor.
NOTE CONF
And so we're reusing the expression and statement visitor structure.
So we implement those two interfaces which are hidden inside
NOTE CONF
their their classes, and we grab an interpreter for whatever
reason, we'll find out what we need.
NOTE CONF
The interpreter for But I was I'm a bit surprised
to see we need one cos I just told you,
NOTE CONF
you don't want to interpret, but let's see, Let's see
what he uses it for.
NOTE CONF
So remembering that interpreting these two means you've got to
implement the all of the visits from each of those
NOTE CONF
each of those interfaces and that those interfaces as you
visit them, you're gonna have, um, you're gonna have more
NOTE CONF
specific types inside.
So let me go through what this, uh, phase is
NOTE CONF
actually gonna do, Uh, when it sees a block statement,
it's gonna introduce a new scope.
NOTE CONF
When it sees a function declaration, it's going to introduce
a new scope.
NOTE CONF
When it sees a variable declaration, it's gonna introduce a
new S.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna add that to the current scope and when
it sees variable assignment expressions and when it says variable
NOTE CONF
use expressions so as opposed to variable declaration expressions.
So he's called those variable and assignment, but he means
NOTE CONF
variable use and or variable assignment.
But I think of assignment as use anyway, um, then
NOTE CONF
we've got to resolve which variable they're talking about.
Sounds like we're kind of redoing the environment thing.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, a little bit.
But it's that last step that's different.
NOTE CONF
In the last step, we just did those three things
and then expected the scoping to work itself out.
NOTE CONF
Now we're doing those three things and being more careful
about, uh, the last one.
NOTE CONF
And as with every semantic analysis phase, it's only interesting
in a few places in every other place, it just
NOTE CONF
has to make sure that the TRAVERSAL continues.
So in every other place, it just says, Well, just
NOTE CONF
do yourself again to all my Children.
So there'll be a lot of visits where it just
NOTE CONF
says, visit means visit.
Visit means visit.
NOTE CONF
Um, but those are the interesting ones.
OK, so what we're doing in this one is we're
NOTE CONF
not creating environments.
That's what the interpreter did.
NOTE CONF
We're making our own little facsimile of environments just within
this semantic analysis phase.
NOTE CONF
Um, by starting up a new scope and ending the
scope and starting a scope and ending a scope is
NOTE CONF
gonna do something.
Um, it's gonna push a kind of really, uh, simple
NOTE CONF
environment onto a stack of environments for us, exactly like
we were thinking we were doing in environments.
NOTE CONF
But it's a simpler version because they're not actually to
store any variables along the way.
NOTE CONF
Um, and we're doing it just inside the the resolver.
And then once the statements of the body have been
NOTE CONF
done, that scope finishes.
So you can guess that's gonna pop off some stack
NOTE CONF
when you're resolving a list of statements.
They don't do anything interesting, so just pass it on
NOTE CONF
each list.
When you're resolving a statement, that just means putting it
NOTE CONF
through the visitor.
When you're resolving an expression that just means putting it
NOTE CONF
through the visitor, you recall before we had interpret and
execute.
NOTE CONF
This time, they've both got the same function just to
resolve.
NOTE CONF
So we've got this stack of maps that we're keeping
track of for our scopes and ends.
NOTE CONF
Scope just pops the top of the stack.
So when you see a variable declaration, you wanna go
NOTE CONF
to the top of the stack and pop that declaration
in there, so that does, and then the rest is
NOTE CONF
just Well, then this one is just checking whether I
need to have, uh, pass the resolve on to another
NOTE CONF
part of the tree and then define statement name.
Let's see what define does so define happens Both times
NOTE CONF
we declare the statement name and we define the statement
name declaring and defining in order to carry Harry Funny
NOTE CONF
Edge cases like declaring and defining versus declaring and defining.
OK, so why is that a funny edge case?
NOTE CONF
It's a funny edge case, because at this point in
the code, you and I all agree.
NOTE CONF
Which a Are we talking about Lane One or Lane
three?
NOTE CONF
See, I've highlighted an A there.
Is that a the line one A or the line?
NOTE CONF
Three A.
Hm.
NOTE CONF
Line one.
Yes, we all agree it's line one, but it could
NOTE CONF
be Lane three because we just declared it had already
been declared.
NOTE CONF
So that's, uh, we have to.
That's why he does it in two steps.
NOTE CONF
Because if he just did it in one, you wouldn't
be able to separate that.
NOTE CONF
A definition happening after a declaration could still refer to
the declaration from before.
NOTE CONF
Can we see why this is a funny case?
We can't.
NOTE CONF
I got quizzical looks.
I'll go through it.
NOTE CONF
I like the quizzical looks.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
This is a funny case, because anytime after a declaration
down here, you're expecting a I mean, this a right,
NOTE CONF
And this is actually after the declaration, but it doesn't
mean that I it means this I Yeah, well, if
NOTE CONF
you made it that way, that would be a would
equal itself.
NOTE CONF
And what the heck does that even mean, Right, But
by S, if I applied simple rules, which was after
NOTE CONF
a new declaration, all A's refer to the newest declaration
it would break.
NOTE CONF
So I have to say, Oh, these ones on the
right hand side when you do a declaration and an
NOTE CONF
assignment together, have to act a little bit different to
the ones where I did VA a equal a right
NOTE CONF
If I'd done VA semicolon a equals a means something
different to this one.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Anyway, so that's what he means by having to split
NOTE CONF
out, declare and define in the line above When really,
we just think Oh, you've seen a variable.
NOTE CONF
So you're gonna you're gonna put that into the the
top of the stack.
NOTE CONF
I said he chooses to make it a compiler error
here.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I disagreed with him when I read this.
So he said out of the three options you've got,
NOTE CONF
um, run the initialise and put the new variable in
scope.
NOTE CONF
Put the new variable in scope and then run the
initialise make it an error to reference a variable in
NOTE CONF
its initialise.
So he says, shadowing is rare and often an error.
NOTE CONF
So initialising a shadowing variable based on the value of
the shadowed one, which is what we just described.
NOTE CONF
And what Isabel said this one should do, seems unlikely
to be deliberate.
NOTE CONF
Uh, no, I actually see this all the time.
This is all the time, especially with, um, function declarations,
NOTE CONF
function declarations.
The parameter list is really just like a little variable
NOTE CONF
declaration at the start of the function, and he heaps
of times It has the same name as the outer
NOTE CONF
Cope, and you want it just to be equal to
the thing from the outer scope because it's the same
NOTE CONF
concept.
Uh, but OK, well, he's he's designing the language.
NOTE CONF
That's OK.
So he chose to make it an error.
NOTE CONF
So he said, No, If you do that, I'm just
gonna tell you that's an error.
NOTE CONF
And that's why he had to split it in two.
Because, um, he needs this.
NOTE CONF
Define if it finds an A.
It needs to complain, whereas later on when we find
NOTE CONF
an A, we just attach to it.
Okey dokey.
NOTE CONF
So hopefully you'll appreciate it.
Anyway, this is a fun last chapter because, you know,
NOTE CONF
we I said from the start, all the nitty gritty,
gritty details have to be sorted out.
NOTE CONF
Well, here we're sorting them out.
OK, so when you declare a token in the name,
NOTE CONF
if there's no scopes, then just be done with.
But if there's a scope, then, um, pop it into
NOTE CONF
the scope.
So let's just look at the top of the stack
NOTE CONF
and put put it in the top of the stack.
Whereas define.
NOTE CONF
He's got this true false, which tells you whether it
should.
NOTE CONF
But hang on.
We bind its name to false because it doesn't have
NOTE CONF
a value yet.
Alright, that that bull and true or false tells you
NOTE CONF
whether you've finished defining it or not.
OK, and then they said this variable to true to
NOTE CONF
market is fully initialised and available for use.
OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
Alright, well, that's one way around it.
But I, I want you to understand this is kind
NOTE CONF
of a key thing in this course and compile.
Uh uh.
NOTE CONF
Interpreted implementation is a lot of choices being made because
what happened in the olden days, you'd read a compiler
NOTE CONF
implementation book, and it would say it's done this way.
It's done this way.
NOTE CONF
It's done this way, and you'd go What?
Jeez, and you wouldn't understand why.
NOTE CONF
And you just think it always had to be done
that way?
NOTE CONF
Um, a classic example is multiple inheritance, uh, multiple inheritance.
Uh, like C++ doesn't allow multiple inheritance because of the
NOTE CONF
diamond inheritance problem, and diamond air pump is trivially solved.
But the L, the people who implemented C++ chose to
NOTE CONF
solve it one way, and then everyone else afterwards just
went, Oh, that's the way you gotta do it.
NOTE CONF
It was never the way you had to do it.
It was just the way one person did it.
NOTE CONF
And this book is better at showing us that, you
know, it's just one person's choice about how to do
NOTE CONF
it.
There are other choices anyway, so that's his choice for
NOTE CONF
this one.
OK, so we're getting there.
NOTE CONF
Um, this is gonna feel a little bit like a
one of these big waves that washes over.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna do diagrams at the end.
I'm pushing on through the implementation before the diagram because
NOTE CONF
I wanna make sure I'm matching exactly what he's saying
by refreshing my brain on it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so if we visit a variable scope So this
is one where we using a variable?
NOTE CONF
Oh, no.
This is the one where we're using it on the
NOTE CONF
right hand side.
Ok, um otherwise we just resolve the local resolve.
NOTE CONF
Local does what we want it to do.
It just goes one up, up, up the scopes looking
NOTE CONF
for the one we need.
And when it finds the one we need, it does
NOTE CONF
interpreter dot resolve.
So now we see what we needed the interpreter for
NOTE CONF
what?
And that interpreter is this interpreter, right?
NOTE CONF
Hang on.
Back up to the top Final Interpreter Interpreter is an
NOTE CONF
interpreter.
Interpreters never resolve.
NOTE CONF
We've got to resolve.
So all the way down here, where did interpreter dot
NOTE CONF
resolve come from?
Alright, let's step on and get there.
NOTE CONF
We start at the innermost scope and work outwards looking
for each map a matching name.
NOTE CONF
If we find the matching name, we resolve it.
Passing the number of scopes between the current innermost scope.
NOTE CONF
Oh, OK, Uh, where the variables found.
So if the variable is found in the current scope,
NOTE CONF
we pass in zero.
If it is in the immediately enclosing scope, you get
NOTE CONF
one.
So here we see his solution.
NOTE CONF
His solution is when I get to a variable, I
want the tree to have been annotated to tell me
NOTE CONF
exactly how many scopes I have to go out to
find it, right.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna push on and then do a diagram.
So just bear with me.
NOTE CONF
When we resolve assignment expressions, we just push them through.
But we resolve local on the name.
NOTE CONF
When we resolve function declarations, we just pass it on.
But then we resolve the function.
NOTE CONF
Resolving a function is exactly the same, except that you
create a new scope.
NOTE CONF
You do the body and you're done.
And then resolving other syntax, three nodes just passes on
NOTE CONF
Same deal for return covers all statements under the expressions.
The expressions almost all just pass on except for um
NOTE CONF
when you are visiting a oh visiting a variable.
Where's the one when you visit a variable visit a
NOTE CONF
call, visit a binary visit a while visit a return
visit a print?
NOTE CONF
Is it an F?
Now?
NOTE CONF
Those are all statements.
OK, we must have already hit.
NOTE CONF
Must have already done visiting variables somewhere interpreting resolved variables.
So let's see what a resolve is good for each
NOTE CONF
time it visits a variable, it tells the interpreter how
many scopes there are between the current scope and the
NOTE CONF
scope of the variable is defined.
What the heck?
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna save it on a tree.
I think it makes sense on a tree.
NOTE CONF
We gonna store that resolution information somewhere so we can
use it.
NOTE CONF
One of these places right in the syntax tree node
itself.
NOTE CONF
That's a fine approach.
That's the approach I would have used.
NOTE CONF
And it's the way I'm still having to get my
head around this.
NOTE CONF
And that's where many compilers, uh, maybe all of them
compile the the results of an analysis like this.
NOTE CONF
We could do that, but it would require mucking about
with our syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
Instead, we'll take another common approach and store it off
to the side in a map that associates each syntax
NOTE CONF
tree with its resolved data.
Alright, I'm good to go now.
NOTE CONF
I can give you a diagram.
I just had to remind myself of that bit cos
NOTE CONF
that was the bit when I was like, Hang on,
hang on, hang on, Hang on.
NOTE CONF
All right, we're gonna do it on this tree Now
we're gonna do it on this programme, so I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
draw the full abstract Syntex tree for this programme.
Tuning in.
NOTE CONF
This is Oh, I gotta share again.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
I'm going to erase the other stuff so that I've
got to pay that better canvas.
NOTE CONF
That's all back in the recording from earlier.
So it's not a big issue.
NOTE CONF
Let's build the abstract syntax tree for this.
So this state, it has one two statements at the
NOTE CONF
top level.
The first statement is the V deo, which is a
NOTE CONF
two global.
The second is the block.
NOTE CONF
OK, so what's inside the block?
We got one statement there.
NOTE CONF
234 statements.
The first statement being a function decor.
NOTE CONF
The second statement being a function call.
I'll just write call there.
NOTE CONF
I'm probably not using the exact right um abstract Syntex
tree names for those the third one being a var
NOTE CONF
deco and the fourth one being a call.
Let's get this out of the way.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the fun deck or the function decal is
show a an empty parameter list and one statement.
NOTE CONF
Well, it's a block kind of kind of a block,
but it doesn't really get stored as a block in
NOTE CONF
this one.
So it's a single statement, which is a print of
NOTE CONF
a night.
Uh, actually, it's a print of a VA, so let's
NOTE CONF
make sure we get that right is a variable use.
Hey, then there's a call to show A with no
NOTE CONF
parameters.
Then there's a V Deco for a to luck.
NOTE CONF
And then there's a call to show a with no
parameters.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I think that's my abstract Syntex tree, Right?
OK, so remember that as the interpreter was working through
NOTE CONF
this, it was building these environments and it got stuck
in a position that was bad.
NOTE CONF
We saw the position it got stuck in.
It got stuck in the position where it had a
NOTE CONF
global with a going to global.
Then it had a local which had show a going
NOTE CONF
to some function, OK, and we did a call to
show a and we got one thing and then we
NOTE CONF
did A goes to block.
And then we did the next show A which created
NOTE CONF
a little environment underneath it by way of our closure.
And we were incorrectly finding that A Yep.
NOTE CONF
And so the reminder of so that was the second
call to show a on the first call to show
NOTE CONF
a the situation looked like I'm just gonna scribble here
because they're the same words show a went to a
NOTE CONF
function.
And when we called Show A, we had a third
NOTE CONF
scope.
But when we went looking for a, we happily went
NOTE CONF
right past this one and found that a agreed.
Now everyone's tuned out.
NOTE CONF
We agreed.
So bad situation, good situation.
NOTE CONF
The good situation was two jumps one two.
The bad situation was one jump, and it would have
NOTE CONF
been good if we'd done two jumps instead.
One.
NOTE CONF
So the key information that he's wanting to store here
is that when I'm down here in this thing, that's
NOTE CONF
the closure, and I go looking for an A.
It should always be two jumps.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
I understand it correctly.
Um, now, closure actually just means a function, a nested
NOTE CONF
function call, and we're using the word closure to represent
the environment.
NOTE CONF
That function has to be called in.
So we focused on the environment, the function when it
NOTE CONF
was defined back over here when it was defined over
here, it was defined inside a particular environment.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and so every time it gets called, it's got
to be called inside that same environment, that environment we
NOTE CONF
call the closure.
And so when that one was defined, it was inside
NOTE CONF
a local scope inside a global Yeah.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So we captured the fact that it was a local
insider Global and C said, the closure for this function
NOTE CONF
call is one local inside one global be because as
soon as you fire up the function core, the third
NOTE CONF
scope comes into existence.
Exactly.
NOTE CONF
So that's his solution.
His solution is just when I'm doing things like this
NOTE CONF
don't just go up the chain like, in fact, it
starts to make you start to wonder why the chain's
NOTE CONF
even there.
But let's leave the chain there for now.
NOTE CONF
Don't just go up the chain.
I'll tell you exactly how far to go up the
NOTE CONF
chain, and you just go up and get it.
So the static analysis phase is adding to the chain
NOTE CONF
a pre computed count of where you're gonna find the
in, Uh, the the the variable that matters to you.
NOTE CONF
So you can see why some of those other solutions
we looked at might be be might seem better, right?
NOTE CONF
They all seem simpler than this.
OK, um but this is all about fitting in the
NOTE CONF
environment he's got, so I'll just go through one other.
Well, the the the more standard alternative.
NOTE CONF
This is our abstract Syntex tree, right?
I'm gonna do the my what I would do and
NOTE CONF
what we did last year.
In our previous version, of course, where we had a
NOTE CONF
a really nice system for writing static analysis.
We would traverse the tree, and every time we saw
NOTE CONF
a variable use, we would point to the appropriate variable
declaration.
NOTE CONF
So I traversed the tree going on here I go
from the top and I go to the V decal
NOTE CONF
and I say that's not a variable use don't care.
And I go back up.
NOTE CONF
I Traver you and go to the block, I say.
All right, let's try your left hand side.
NOTE CONF
You're a function declaration, OK?
I don't care.
NOTE CONF
Oh, yes, I do I've got to look in your
body.
NOTE CONF
So I check the body.
You're a prim.
NOTE CONF
I better check your buddy.
I see the van.
NOTE CONF
You V.
OK, right now what variable called a Do I know
NOTE CONF
about the only one I've seen so far.
Is that one over there?
NOTE CONF
So I say, Uh huh, that's you.
And then I back up and then I go into
NOTE CONF
the call and I say all I better check your
parameters and I find nothing.
NOTE CONF
And then I go back up and then I go
to the variable declaration and I go, Ha!
NOTE CONF
You're a new verbal declaration, but I don't care cos
I'm only doing verbal use.
NOTE CONF
So I go back up and then I go down
to the verbal call and I say you're a show.
NOTE CONF
A better check your parameters.
No parameters done.
NOTE CONF
And so what happens here is that now when the
interpreter gets to an A, it's not looking through any
NOTE CONF
global scopes, or you just go straight to that one
and it says you're my man.
NOTE CONF
You're the A that I was talking about.
There's no way I'm gonna get confused with this one
NOTE CONF
over here because I've got a direct line to you.
Yeah, The downside of that is that the V abstract
NOTE CONF
syntax tree node would have to have an extra field.
It would have a field for the variable in fine,
NOTE CONF
which we've already got, and then it would have a
field for Who's Your Associated declaration?
NOTE CONF
And that field would be an expression because it would
point off to the verbal declaration expression.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, that's the solution he's talking about.
That requires an adjustment to the A ST generator that
NOTE CONF
he chooses not to go down.
That, I think, is by far the most understandable explanation.
NOTE CONF
But you get a cool insight into tree traversal here
with his real solu the solution he actually uses.
NOTE CONF
So he says, I don't want to muck with my
abstract syntax trick.
NOTE CONF
What alternatives are there?
One alternative is the absolutely standard, but you've probably never
NOTE CONF
seen it before.
Technique in programming of mapping one node to another in
NOTE CONF
a totally separate data structure, instead of adding a single
extra field to the tree, which would end up being
NOTE CONF
black in my diagram, right, cos it's part of the
abstract syntax tree, Um, instead, I'll do the instead one
NOTE CONF
in green.
Instead, I'm gonna leave the black tree entirely alone.
NOTE CONF
But remember, I'm in object on gland, so every single
node has, like a a special number or something, like
NOTE CONF
a reference to it.
I al they've all got their own identity.
NOTE CONF
So this one's got an identity.
This one's got an identity.
NOTE CONF
Let's call the identity of this one alpha and the
identity of this one Beta.
NOTE CONF
They're both expressions, right?
Uh, well, that one, the top one's a statement the
NOTE CONF
second.
So Alpha is an expression in this case and and
NOTE CONF
made a statement.
All I really want is to make sure that when
NOTE CONF
I see the Alpha I know I'm pointing to the
beta.
NOTE CONF
I can just keep a separate data structure that just
goes.
NOTE CONF
Alpha and beta are the ones that are related.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
So that's another map.
That's what he creates, he says.
NOTE CONF
Look, instead of adjusting my abstract Syntex tree in place,
the interpreter is going to keep track of this extra
NOTE CONF
thing here that associates alpha with beta, and it's gonna
use it when it needs to.
NOTE CONF
So now his syntax, his syntax analysis, goes round the
tree, so it goes from top, gets to var Deco
NOTE CONF
and goes This is probably gonna matter.
So I'm gonna pop this in my stack of things
NOTE CONF
and then it goes back up.
When it gets down to the A, it goes, Oh,
NOTE CONF
that that thing mattered.
I better go find it.
NOTE CONF
So it does.
And I'm gonna send off to the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Hey, Interpreter.
I just found an important mapping Alpha Beta, and the
NOTE CONF
interpreter goes Cool.
I'll put that in my list and I'll move on.
NOTE CONF
But in fact, what's the beta he uses here?
It's the number of steps cos the interpreter already is
NOTE CONF
keeping track of this over here, So it's actually a
nice way for him to store it is to go
NOTE CONF
Ah, well, Alpha is associated with, uh uh, the number
two because it's you're gonna have to go two steps
NOTE CONF
back up, which I can tell from my diagram.
That's fine.
NOTE CONF
I could tell because I went inside a block, so
I know I'm at number two, so that's what we
NOTE CONF
send to the interpreter.
So now the interpreter's got these environments that grow and
NOTE CONF
shrink dynamically, and it's got this name resolution which says
when you get to name A I mean, I got
NOTE CONF
an alpha here, but he'll just put a in there,
right When you get to name A, make sure you
NOTE CONF
go two steps up to find the right one.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Um, so I get this idea, but did you have
another thing?
NOTE CONF
Because those right in, But I can.
Then doesn't it clash in the map?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, you're probably right.
He probably does put Alpha in there, But the reason
NOTE CONF
Alpha's OK is because there's never another Alpha Alpha represents
this object in the tree.
NOTE CONF
And so when you get to another VA, it's a
whole another node in the tree.
NOTE CONF
And so it's got its own identity.
Is that Is it, like, just give me another gargle?
NOTE CONF
Uh, environment.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Another one of overhead.
It is some overhead, but it's not a lot.
NOTE CONF
Um, So you're gonna be doing this in this case,
you're gonna do that traversal anyway, so it actually makes
NOTE CONF
it faster cos you don't have to do any if
you don't have to do any if statements as you
NOTE CONF
go up the traversal, you just go.
I'm going twice.
NOTE CONF
Bam, bam!
Done.
NOTE CONF
Um, and it moves a little bit of the work
from run time to compile time.
NOTE CONF
It really run time from yeah to before run time.
Uh, but again, like I said, this is just one
NOTE CONF
solution.
This is the one that fit for his architecture and
NOTE CONF
his interpreter.
Most people will know this problem's coming from the very
NOTE CONF
start, and they won't have any problems putting an extra
field into their abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
That's fine, but one of his pedagogical things is he
wants his abstract syntax tree to be a close representation
NOTE CONF
of the PAS, the grammar.
And none of this was mentioned in the grammar.
NOTE CONF
So it feels weird if you're building the abstract syntax
tree from the grammar to go.
NOTE CONF
Oh, but there's an extra thing I'll have to put
in there for later.
NOTE CONF
That's only got to do with interpretation.
Yep, OK, And so as we go through this, we
NOTE CONF
are reminded of the genius of the Kama system, which
was last year's, which, unfortunately, we're not using it.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, I'm just reminded.
So I, I told you at the start this is
NOTE CONF
the new version of the course from the old version
of the course.
NOTE CONF
Um And the old version, of course, used Scala.
And it had a library on top of that called
NOTE CONF
Kama.
And there was a trick you were able to do
NOTE CONF
that didn't require you to change the a ST, but
still require it still enabled you to annotate it with
NOTE CONF
these new things.
Uh, and it's super cool.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but it only works in Scala.
So we had to We would have had to stay
NOTE CONF
in Scala to stick with that.
OK, uh but yeah, every now and then I'm just
NOTE CONF
reminded, uh of how cool Scarlett can be.
And that's another example.
NOTE CONF
I could go into how Scara supports the yellow version
instead of the green version.
NOTE CONF
But we'll do that another day.
Alright, so now we've got that concept sorted right?
NOTE CONF
That was a long way to solve this problem.
But where do we end up?
NOTE CONF
But we ended up with a new traversal.
But it was it's a self contained traversal.
NOTE CONF
In most ways, it stored its own stack of environments
like cos when it saw a block, it added something
NOTE CONF
to the stack.
And when it saw the function declaration, it added something
NOTE CONF
to that stack.
So it was a a traversal of the a ST
NOTE CONF
that was keeping track of a a small piece of
its own data, a stack of of scopes.
NOTE CONF
And then when it found something that was important to
the interpreter, it fired that off to the interpreter, and
NOTE CONF
the interpreter added an extra, um, an extra data structure
to help store the information that came from that.
NOTE CONF
I'll just show you where that comes up.
OK, so that's this thing here.
NOTE CONF
The interpreter added, This this new structure, it's just static.
It doesn't change, um, to store the mapping from an
NOTE CONF
expression to how many jumps it should be so that
every time that, um, static analysis phase reported one, it
NOTE CONF
could just add it in there.
Right?
NOTE CONF
But that's that question you asked.
Yeah, but each expression node, uh, is its own Java
NOTE CONF
object with its own unique identity.
I think a lot of people lose track of that,
NOTE CONF
and I think we're not, uh, we I mean, Macquarie.
I mean, educators in general, or programmers in general aren't
NOTE CONF
really good at expressing the identity that every object has
in an object owned system.
NOTE CONF
If you did garbage collection, perhaps somewhere along the way,
you'd have to deal with it.
NOTE CONF
Um and we we would hope to do garbage collection.
Of course, we couldn't fit it in.
NOTE CONF
Uh huh.
But if you do the second half of the book,
NOTE CONF
you get to learn about garbage collection.
OK, so I think.
NOTE CONF
OK, so there's a few more things they're doing during
this semantic analysis here as well.
NOTE CONF
So I was called this name analysis, Um, and and
so he he does a couple of other things.
NOTE CONF
He says, I I'll be able to check if you've
redecorated a variable during this phase, that might be useful.
NOTE CONF
And by telling you that before I fire up the
interpreter, I can give you your errors earlier So he
NOTE CONF
goes through how to do that.
He's just looking for this situation where you redefine the
NOTE CONF
same variable in a scope which most languages don't allow.
Personally, I'm like, Why not allow?
NOTE CONF
It's just the same situation as before, but whatever, that's
me.
NOTE CONF
And so you've got the facility to do that right
now in the resolver you just if the keys already
NOTE CONF
there when you try to add it, then complain that
it's there nice.
NOTE CONF
He can also check for returns in the wrong place.
So at this point, this resolver knows how many scopes
NOTE CONF
deep it is and what kind of scope it's inside
of.
NOTE CONF
So if it you try to return from a block
or return at the global level, it can tell you
NOTE CONF
that was the bad thing to do.
So he does that.
NOTE CONF
And then he goes back up to the top and
just runs the static.
NOTE CONF
What he calls the resolver the name analysis.
He just does it earlier and doesn't try and interpret
NOTE CONF
if a, uh, an error comes back.
So now we really do in our interpreter have, um
NOTE CONF
a passing phase analysis phase and an interpreted phase, and
they just happen one after the other.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, The best way to think of the analysis phase
is that all the things you'd expect the ID E
NOTE CONF
to do for you anything where you expect to see
a red squiggly line appear in your ID E should
NOTE CONF
be done by a static analysis that just visits each
node of the tree ones.
NOTE CONF
And you have a question many good, good.
Start it wherever you wanna start.
NOTE CONF
Like can we look at the diagram on the thing?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
OK, wait.
So the motivation for this chapter is to fix the
NOTE CONF
problem we saw at the start.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
To fix the fact that that second show a prints
block instead of global and then checking all the yep,
NOTE CONF
And the other ways you could solve Hold on.
You mentioned some languages, generate another D, or was it
NOTE CONF
adding an extra expression?
So that's what this yellow one is that's adding an
NOTE CONF
extra field to the A ST, which would be the
normal approach, I would think, Um, but the other the
NOTE CONF
other ways of solving it at the language level that
I mean, because that's at the compiler level.
NOTE CONF
At the language level.
I said you could implement hoisting, or you could force
NOTE CONF
all the decorations to be at the top.
But those are the language level because they I.
NOTE CONF
I impact the programmer, whereas exactly what we do inside
here with the same semantics doesn't impact the programmer.
NOTE CONF
It just impacts us.
All right?
NOTE CONF
Should we now look at a language where none of
this matters?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
OK, so a a.
NOTE CONF
Another reason I like finishing with this is that it's
brought all of the side effect problems to the surface.
NOTE CONF
Um, just a very simple side effect, Like declaring a
variable part way down a block, has just kind of
NOTE CONF
poof exploded our little nice little world, and we've had
to start bolting bits on left, right and centre.
NOTE CONF
And it's probably a fair cognitive load for you guys
to get your head around this.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and that's just a tiny little bit.
Compiler Riders have got hundreds of these to deal with.
NOTE CONF
So in the late seventies early eighties, a bunch of
people said, Hang that, uh, let's make the we should
NOTE CONF
just do a language that, you know, when none of
this stuff comes up and, uh, see how that works
NOTE CONF
out.
And if you've checked what we're doing that language is
NOTE CONF
has can make a bigger So that is probably the
language I most recommend you to learn as an intellectual
NOTE CONF
endeavour.
And, uh, there are there is work available.
NOTE CONF
It is a It is a proper industrial language that
companies are built around.
NOTE CONF
So there are jobs in high school.
And when you go looking for when, uh, if you
NOTE CONF
are skilled in high school.
The jobs come to you, you don't go to them.
NOTE CONF
You just like, fling out to the world.
I know how school and a bunch of people come
NOTE CONF
to you and go, Please work for us.
Um, so in Australia, who's using it?
NOTE CONF
I'm trying to think it's a There's a couple of
big names like Sales force or some other big places
NOTE CONF
like that are using Tesco in some places, but also
a lot of start ups.
NOTE CONF
But at the same time, it's another one of these
languages that's at its peak and is settling into a
NOTE CONF
second tier area.
It's not gonna become the new Rust or Java or
NOTE CONF
C, OS plus or whatever, but there's There's plenty of
second tier languages out there that have their place, and
NOTE CONF
our school very specifically has a different place to all
the others because it is it.
NOTE CONF
It's the only language that occupies its space in the
language design.
NOTE CONF
What are we gonna call it?
Plane.
NOTE CONF
If you think of that, maybe a three or four
or five or six dimensional plane where you make each
NOTE CONF
of the language design decisions, where do you end up
in there?
NOTE CONF
Haskell's alone, whereas Java's got C# for company and C++
for company and Rust has got go for company and
NOTE CONF
C for company was Haskell's got nobody for company.
So the big design decisions in high school were no
NOTE CONF
side effects.
None whatsoever.
NOTE CONF
Um, and lazy evaluation by default.
You don't even know what lazy evaluation is because you've
NOTE CONF
never come across it.
Well, you've seen it in one place.
NOTE CONF
Lazy evaluation has to exist in a language somewhere or
it's not true And complete which short circuit on an
NOTE CONF
on a Boolean expression?
Yes.
NOTE CONF
So Haskell takes that idea where if I don't have
to compute the whole expression, I won't.
NOTE CONF
I'll only compute the bits I need and makes it
core to its existence.
NOTE CONF
So here I am, in the Glasgow Haskell Compiler Interpreter.
Oh, Interactive.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Which gives me a little repel for interacting with Haskell
NOTE CONF
in the olden days.
High school had multiple implementations, uh, most of which were
NOTE CONF
centred around university.
So there was a York Haskill interpreter.
NOTE CONF
There was a Chalmers Haskill interpreter.
There was a Glasgow High School interpreter in the US.
NOTE CONF
They created the Haskill Users gopher system, but, um, it's
settled down and it's it's all GHC now.
NOTE CONF
And the high school community is entirely focused around GHC.
Uh, but I'm just gonna bring up the book over
NOTE CONF
here so I can make sure.
I mean, I'm gonna stick to week.
NOTE CONF
I'm mostly gonna stick to day One things, but there's
a few fun things I wanna show off that aren't
NOTE CONF
Day one.
Um, so they interviewed Waddler, I think.
NOTE CONF
Who was one of these?
When I said the grunt people got together in the
NOTE CONF
late seventies, early eighties, they were all from Western Europe.
They were all centred around the Oxbridge kind of area,
NOTE CONF
Um, but including the West of Europe and Scotland and
Ireland, and some of the Americans came over.
NOTE CONF
But there's, like, a core group of maybe a dozen
people who drove this language, and they're all still quite
NOTE CONF
influential in programming languages.
Uh, they've all gone on to work at big places.
NOTE CONF
Facebook, Microsoft, uh, the main guys now at Epic games.
For some reason, they wanted a high school guy.
NOTE CONF
Um, I think they just had a bit too much
money, and they're just, like, accumulating as much of the
NOTE CONF
world's intelligence as they could, hoping that something would come
of it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but no.
Sometimes it does, uh, crafting interpreters.
NOTE CONF
Why, that's so SL.
OK, but, uh, so the next thing to say, uh,
NOTE CONF
it's an expression based language, but it's got that in
common with a lot of the other functional languages, like
NOTE CONF
closure and IO.
And so those sort of expression based, but really genuinely
NOTE CONF
everything is an expression right to the point that you
know how we discussed that, Um, values are numerical values,
NOTE CONF
literals or whatever and un evaluated functions.
That's how you should think about everything in high school.
NOTE CONF
It's either just a value or an uninterpreted function waiting
to be run.
NOTE CONF
And if I give you an interpreted function and enough
values, it'll interpret it for you to get another value.
NOTE CONF
And that will be either one of these low values
or another uninterpreted function, which gives you the, um, another
NOTE CONF
understanding of why it's called functional programming.
Ah, I just realised I gotta go through the whole
NOTE CONF
thing, um, through the library to get there, so But
I gotta do it to make sure I don't do
NOTE CONF
the wrong stuff.
They do.
NOTE CONF
I left my copy of the book in my office
today.
NOTE CONF
If this makes me log in with two factor authentication,
I'm gonna go do Lily.
NOTE CONF
OK, now, this is making me crazy that Yeah, I
know.
NOTE CONF
Oh, my goodness.
OK, let's see.
NOTE CONF
All right, I got that.
Did I?
NOTE CONF
No.
My God, this is going to come on!
NOTE CONF
My apologies means my God, you're gonna kill me!
M, It's a downloaded version where the index doesn't work.
NOTE CONF
I've got scroll, Scroll, scroll!
OK, close up.
NOTE CONF
I know that.
Think we that No, we're not there.
NOTE CONF
Uh, all right, we're there A few.
Ok, alright.
NOTE CONF
So expression based language.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Very good.
Um, right now I gotta start GHC I.
NOTE CONF
So again, with most of the rebel, you know, it
tells you you're in the shell for that language instead
NOTE CONF
of just in your normal shell.
And like most of the rebel, you give it an
NOTE CONF
expression, and it just evaluates it for you and returns
the value.
NOTE CONF
Uh, one cool thing that Haskell does is it decides
there's no such thing as a Well, there is a
NOTE CONF
character, but there's no such thing as a string.
A string is actually a list of characters.
NOTE CONF
I believe Let's see what it does.
Yeah, Instead of having a separate string type, it just
NOTE CONF
says, Well, it's just a list of characters.
So, uh, this is notation for a list, By the
NOTE CONF
way, square brackets on either side.
That's it.
NOTE CONF
Notation for types.
It's got two colons for types and that colon tea
NOTE CONF
is how I pass a little instructions to the interpreter
that aren't part of the language.
NOTE CONF
So I got Colon T for type.
I got Colon Q for quit.
NOTE CONF
I got colon exclamation mark for execute in the T
A bunch of things.
NOTE CONF
Um, so then I can just use standard listings to
do stuff with strings, and that just seems so obvious
NOTE CONF
once you've seen it.
Um, the fact that I've got different list functions for
NOTE CONF
getting the first element of a list as I have
different string functions for getting the first character of a
NOTE CONF
string kind of seems stupid once you've had to worry
about it again.
NOTE CONF
Um, it is a bit of a performance kick, though,
like Haskell literally stores them as lists of strings.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and so Haskell has created a bike string, which
is a way of making old style strings.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and people will use bike strings if they need
to be faster.
NOTE CONF
But for most of us, we just use normal strings
and we don't worry about it.
NOTE CONF
It's got all the standard bullions.
It's got a very strong type system.
NOTE CONF
So something that might work in another language, like one
plus one, where another language says no, Look, I can
NOTE CONF
tell that's a string on the left.
So you probably just want to, uh, use string concatenation
NOTE CONF
instead of addition.
Our school says no, no, no, we're not doing that.
NOTE CONF
Um, if you wanna do concatenation of strings, you've got
to do it with a double.
NOTE CONF
Plus, that's a separate thing.
Um, and and we're not gonna mix the two.
NOTE CONF
That's not a good idea.
Uh, so pluses is only for numbers, and in fact,
NOTE CONF
Haskell is very strict about a lot of things, and
that's one of the benefits of it.
NOTE CONF
The the benefits of the strictness come from the fact
that at compile time, you can tell a lot of
NOTE CONF
things are correct, way more than you can in a
language of less strictness.
NOTE CONF
But the downside is that you often have to do
a bit more work at compile time or, in fact,
NOTE CONF
a lot more work at compile time.
Um, to make sense of things H school does.
NOTE CONF
It's got no side effects, but it does have variables.
Um, I can do let X equals five X plus
NOTE CONF
X and get 10.
So I've created a variable and given it the value
NOTE CONF
five.
But what I can't do is change the variable value.
NOTE CONF
Uh, there's no updating X to 10.
Oh, I did something.
NOTE CONF
Ah, but the old X is gone now, Um, so
that's actually a brand new X, and that's what I
NOTE CONF
was expecting to have happen.
Um, so every time you make a new variable or
NOTE CONF
or assign in a variable in high school, it actually
makes a brand new variable for you.
NOTE CONF
The old one is shadowed, gone away.
And that's because high school doesn't keep an environment of
NOTE CONF
variables.
Right?
NOTE CONF
I said, There's no side effects, so there's no side
effect.
NOTE CONF
There can't be.
You can't go off to the environment and adjust the
NOTE CONF
variable in the environment.
Uh, what you can do, though, is you can create
NOTE CONF
a new variable.
Uh, and that kind of goes in the environment, but
NOTE CONF
it's not quite an environment because it's not really updating.
Um, so new variables can come into existence, but it's
NOTE CONF
actually just like the step we did just then in
locks.
NOTE CONF
It's actually just that resolving step.
All it's doing is going through, and every time you
NOTE CONF
find a variable, it's linking it to the place where
you defined what the variable was and says That's it
NOTE CONF
that a is always five.
Go to a different part of the tree.
NOTE CONF
You've got another A and maybe it's the five.
If it's the 10, it's gotta be a totally separate
NOTE CONF
part of the tree.
So we, uh, that's not really an environment.
NOTE CONF
There's that.
It's much more the the kind of semi environment we
NOTE CONF
were building.
Uh, as I said, that values are good, but uninterpreted
NOTE CONF
functions are super important, so you basically can do anything
you want with functions.
NOTE CONF
So let's look at a basic function.
Well, plus is a basic function.
NOTE CONF
Um oh, I need to do it like this.
There you go.
NOTE CONF
So it's it says it's given me an error, but
it's actually giving me an error that says, I don't
NOTE CONF
know how to print out what you gave me.
I don't know how to print out a function.
NOTE CONF
Plus, and this is, uh, in locks.
Remember?
NOTE CONF
We said if you try and print out a function,
maybe it comes out in an error.
NOTE CONF
We just write, like, function, the word function or something.
Um, in high school, they go No, no, I can't.
NOTE CONF
I can't print a function.
Um, that would be printing the whole body of the
NOTE CONF
function and that you could do that, I guess.
But deep in the, you know, deep in the philosophy
NOTE CONF
of Haskell is that these un evaluated functions exist.
But you can't see them until you give them their
NOTE CONF
arguments and then they'll result in a value that can
be printed.
NOTE CONF
But there are about an uninterpreted.
Function is a value in the language.
NOTE CONF
Five is a value that can be printed.
An interpretative function is a value that can't be printed.
NOTE CONF
Ah, but the key to that is I can say
let X equal plus and it happily lets me do
NOTE CONF
that.
It's only when I try and print the X.
NOTE CONF
And so I should now be able to do X
78 and get 15 and seven dash X 916.
NOTE CONF
Um, so the function itself can be given.
New names pass around.
NOTE CONF
It's it's a fully first class citizen if I ask
for the type of X, just a little insight into
NOTE CONF
paal types.
But big insight.
NOTE CONF
Um, High School's got a super cool type system that
infers the type for you and doesn't just infer the
NOTE CONF
type.
It infers the most general type so that you can
NOTE CONF
use that place in the most possible ways.
So you and I know that plus works in in
NOTE CONF
most languages.
We expected I showed you the plus didn't work on
NOTE CONF
strings, but it definitely works on integers.
Floats doubles at least those three right?
NOTE CONF
So if you ask for the type of plus, should
it be an integer to an integer to an integer?
NOTE CONF
Take two integers and give me an integer.
Should it be taking two floats and give me a
NOTE CONF
float?
Should it be taking one in one float and give
NOTE CONF
me a float?
What should it be in all languages?
NOTE CONF
You'll have to have eight different implementations of plus and
you'll overload them and then when you call, plus the
NOTE CONF
language goes, Oh, he gave me an integer or float.
So he means this version of Plus High School does
NOTE CONF
better than that.
He says, No, no, I can use the same plus
NOTE CONF
all the time.
Um and so pretty much, no matter what you give
NOTE CONF
me, I'll take in two arguments.
This is its notation for taking in two arguments and
NOTE CONF
giving back at one value.
I'll take in two arguments and give it back just
NOTE CONF
as long as the argument you give me is a
number.
NOTE CONF
And then whatever, I can do it.
It's fine.
NOTE CONF
So that's a more general type.
And that actually saves us from a bunch of OO
NOTE CONF
programming because we don't have to inherit from things to
get this kind of polymorphism.
NOTE CONF
You just get polymorphism straight off the bat as a
functional language.
NOTE CONF
It actually doesn't have loops.
No, while no fours.
NOTE CONF
So if you want to leap, you use recursion or
first class functions.
NOTE CONF
Um, so maybe let's just try something.
Does he do the first class functions here?
NOTE CONF
He doesn't get the ch de Boer.
Do we do patent matching?
NOTE CONF
Yes, we do patent matching.
OK, let's look at that.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the next thing to say.
Well, he gives the example of the Fibonacci numbers, which
NOTE CONF
is always fun.
It also it's got some nice built in structures for
NOTE CONF
you.
So lists built in is obviously nice.
NOTE CONF
And you can do this or whatever you want.
Triples are also built in, so we've seen drupal in
NOTE CONF
other languages.
But the only difference between a list and a tuple
NOTE CONF
is that a drupal can have multiple different types in
it.
NOTE CONF
Right.
Um, when you do a list you would be used
NOTE CONF
to What's the notation for getting the first element of
that list where you expect it to be?
NOTE CONF
Maybe something like this.
But how?
NOTE CONF
School doesn't like that, Um, how school doesn't let you
do that.
NOTE CONF
Hasco doesn't let you just go randomly into a list
and get an element out.
NOTE CONF
You could only grab the start of it or the
end of it.
NOTE CONF
Well, the rest of it in a fast way.
Um so if I ask for the head of a
NOTE CONF
list, I get one.
If I ask for the tail of a list, Oops,
NOTE CONF
I get the remainder of the list, which in this
case is two.
NOTE CONF
But if I put a three there.
I get the remainder of that list.
NOTE CONF
Just like with link lists.
You can only actually access them one at a time.
NOTE CONF
Now, of course, as O is not so painful as
to make you always do it that way.
NOTE CONF
It's got functions, right?
I can say get I don't This is not the
NOTE CONF
function name, But I could maybe say something like that.
Get the third element from that function and there'll be
NOTE CONF
some built in function to do it.
Hm.
NOTE CONF
There is a double exclamation as well.
I want to show because that's just another function.
NOTE CONF
Unless, yeah, and all of this combines to give you
the power you need to get the job done.
NOTE CONF
Um, nothing.
The fact that nothing changes like there's no side effects
NOTE CONF
means that every function where you think maybe it changes
this list or changes this structure, it actually just returns
NOTE CONF
you a new one.
So when you appended to a list, it doesn't change
NOTE CONF
the original list.
It gives you back a new list, and that's gonna
NOTE CONF
feel super inefficient.
But the internals of has of the GHC is designed
NOTE CONF
to Ma to to find all the optimisations that are
there and apply them.
NOTE CONF
You as a programmer only have to think I nothing
gets modified in place.
NOTE CONF
I always get a new one.
And then I leave it to the compiler to work
NOTE CONF
out When, uh, it should be sharing data versus when
it should be creating new ones all the time.
NOTE CONF
OK, everything goes in a main function composition.
So we just saw head and tail.
NOTE CONF
Those are two functions.
I'll just do the type again just to show you
NOTE CONF
show off Head's a function.
Uh, this is the notation in high school to say
NOTE CONF
Head is a function, and its type is I take
one parameter That's a list, and I give back an
NOTE CONF
element from that list.
So I don't care what this is a list of.
NOTE CONF
I don't have to have a capital O object type.
You can give me a list of anything and, uh,
NOTE CONF
head more work on that list.
Same with these are functions by the way, head and
NOTE CONF
tail, they're not built in operators or anything.
They're just functions.
NOTE CONF
If you give me a list, I'll give you back
another list that's of the same type.
NOTE CONF
But it'll be one shorter.
I can't put that in my in in my type,
NOTE CONF
right?
So we got the head of 123.
NOTE CONF
If I wanted to get the second element of 123,
I might say Right first, get the tail of 123,
NOTE CONF
and then get the head of whatever's left that's gonna
give me two, right.
NOTE CONF
Uh, has school actually lets you to write that exact
same programme in a slightly different way.
NOTE CONF
You can compose two functions without ever thinking about the
arguments that are getting given to them with this dot
NOTE CONF
notation and to create a brand new function but gets
the second element.
NOTE CONF
OK, so Head Tail has just been created as a
brand new function that takes in a list and gives
NOTE CONF
back just one element from that list.
Which one does it give?
NOTE CONF
Well, we'll find out by running it, but we can
guess it's the second one.
NOTE CONF
And so I've got the two notations.
I can either run tail and then pass it to
NOTE CONF
head, or I can compose head and tail and just
give it an argument.
NOTE CONF
And that's actually one of the things people love about
hasco.
NOTE CONF
Whoops.
Do I need to put that in parenthesis?
NOTE CONF
Probably.
There's a do.
NOTE CONF
There you go.
Head dot tail is a new function.
NOTE CONF
123 is its input.
Off we go.
NOTE CONF
Um, we're gonna do a bit of pattern matching and
list comprehensions, right?
NOTE CONF
No, that's not No, no, no, Rangers.
Let's go.
NOTE CONF
OK, so, back to lists.
How do we create data in a logical language?
NOTE CONF
You create yourself a class, um, that describes the structure.
Then you make an object from that class, and that
NOTE CONF
brings it into existence.
In high school, you create data?
NOTE CONF
Well, we just created those lists just by writing them
out.
NOTE CONF
But that was a fancy string.
Literal syntax.
NOTE CONF
Um, in our school, you create data by calling one
of its constructors and lists has two different constructors, one
NOTE CONF
of which is called nil.
No.
NOTE CONF
What does it use?
Oh, it just uses the square brackets, one of which
NOTE CONF
is the square brackets, which creates an empty list.
And the other one is the colon doesn't like it.
NOTE CONF
Um, the other one is the colon, which takes an
existing list and adds another element to it.
NOTE CONF
So if I add one to the front of an
empty list.
NOTE CONF
I get the list with one in it.
If I add two to the front of that list,
NOTE CONF
I get the list of two.
And if I had three to the front of that,
NOTE CONF
Um, so that's actually how data is built up in
high school.
NOTE CONF
Always the the hard way.
And sometimes you get access to a nice notation that'll
NOTE CONF
let you do it in an easier way, which you
do in lists.
NOTE CONF
Cases?
Um, same with strings, I think.
NOTE CONF
Right, Let's try this.
A colon empty string.
NOTE CONF
That's me adding the character A to the front of
an empty list.
NOTE CONF
And it goes, Oh, I know what lists of characters
are.
NOTE CONF
They're strings.
So then I can add B to the front.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I gotta get the other car.
I can add B to the front of, uh, a
NOTE CONF
and and I get B A so I can build
up strings in exactly the same way.
NOTE CONF
Why is this cool?
This is cool because the same way you build up
NOTE CONF
any piece of data in high school is how you
can pull apart any data in high school.
NOTE CONF
How do you pull apart stuff in an object on
the language.
NOTE CONF
We have to go into the fields.
You have to call some accessor or method, right?
NOTE CONF
I just made myself a a square class.
How do I find out the size of its side?
NOTE CONF
I go square dot width and I find out the
side of its size.
NOTE CONF
I've got one way to construct it.
New square.
NOTE CONF
I've got another way to pull it apart square dot
with in our school, the two go together, you build
NOTE CONF
and you deconstruct in exactly the same way.
So I can do if I say that ABC, This
NOTE CONF
is a pack match.
If I say the thing on the right was built
NOTE CONF
this way, then please make the A match the right
part.
NOTE CONF
The B match the right part and the C match
the right part.
NOTE CONF
In this case, the A is gonna match the one.
Because if it was built this way, I must have
NOTE CONF
built it by putting a one there a two there
and then, uh, a list that had three in it.
NOTE CONF
There.
The only way I could have done it.
NOTE CONF
So this line will turn a into one.
B into two and C into the rest of three.
NOTE CONF
It'll destruct it in exactly the same way it was
constructed.
NOTE CONF
OK, and that's super cool.
And so a lot of the things that feel like
NOTE CONF
restrictions like data has to be copied.
You can't change the value of variables.
NOTE CONF
All disappear once you get the benefits that come from
that, like destructing data in exactly the same way as
NOTE CONF
you construct it.
First class functions and all the rest of it.
NOTE CONF
So they give us a couple more ways to build,
and now these are a S.
NOTE CONF
This is pure syntactic sugar.
OK, Haskell's got a lot of syntactic.
NOTE CONF
Well, a lot.
It's got some syntactic sugar, and you should actually think
NOTE CONF
of everything as syntactic sugar.
It's, well, anything Sorry.
NOTE CONF
You should actually think of lots of things as syntactic
sugar.
NOTE CONF
It's one of those languages I described.
That's got the small core of concepts, and when it
NOTE CONF
wants to give you some extra facilities, it does them
just as as syntactic sugar, and you can understand what
NOTE CONF
they are in terms of the core language.
Um, but Ranges is one of those, so 1 to
NOTE CONF
2 is not very interesting, but 1 to 200 is
much more interesting.
NOTE CONF
I just get the list of 1 to 200 blah,
blah, blah.
NOTE CONF
Um, it shows me I can do it with steps
and things like that.
NOTE CONF
The other really cool one, Which is I got stolen
by python, so you might be familiar with it, which
NOTE CONF
is list comprehensions.
It's a way of building a list that feels a
NOTE CONF
bit like a loop.
Quite often you're using a loop to build a list
NOTE CONF
or modify a list.
Right?
NOTE CONF
And in high school, building a list is modifying.
A list is the same as building a list cos
NOTE CONF
you can't modify anything.
You can only build a new one.
NOTE CONF
So let's make an interesting list.
1 to 10.
NOTE CONF
Got it.
We'll give it a name.
NOTE CONF
X equals 1 to 10.
We look at X, we see 1 to 10.
NOTE CONF
What happens if I wanna double every element in that
list?
NOTE CONF
I can't.
There's no way to traverse a list and double every
NOTE CONF
item.
I can build a new list.
NOTE CONF
I'm really just wanting to build a new list that's
got the number 2468 10 in it right.
NOTE CONF
So a list of comprehension lets me build a new
list from an old list.
NOTE CONF
And the way it does that is it says tell
me the old list that you're interested in.
NOTE CONF
Oops, Um, we'll call this a Let's do it this
way.
NOTE CONF
OK, tell me the old list you're interested in X.
And with this notation, you're telling me, Just go one
NOTE CONF
by one through that list and get, And every time
you go through that list, call it a and then
NOTE CONF
what I want you to spit out for the new
list is eight times two.
NOTE CONF
So now I'll go through the old list every element
and I'll double it and put that into the new
NOTE CONF
list.
And so this is how I modify a list.
NOTE CONF
Construct a new list from an old list, whatever it
is.
NOTE CONF
But you don't write a loop to modify a list.
You write a list comprehension, which has, you know, what's
NOTE CONF
the list you're starting from on the right.
What's the, um, expression for generating new elements from the
NOTE CONF
list?
And then off you go, I'm gonna show you something
NOTE CONF
else.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
At this point, you can do all kinds of crazy
things with list comprehensions that the book shows a little
NOTE CONF
bit of.
But one thing I wanna show at this point is,
NOTE CONF
uh, laziness kicks in.
Um, let's try.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna make So you just saw that that
printed that whole list out on the screen as soon
NOTE CONF
as I evaluated it?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
You printed out a times two.
I wonder if I can do the S.
NOTE CONF
Just give me a sec.
I'm just wondering if I can make this work.
NOTE CONF
X mod P with P already Hens in those jus.
OK, so I just want to show off, Um, the
NOTE CONF
laziness of high school by showing that one thing you
can get from laziness is you can work with infinite
NOTE CONF
data structures without crashing a computer.
So let's say I had a list of 1000 elements
NOTE CONF
in Java and I say build this list of 1000
elements and Java goes, Yeah, sure, Fine.
NOTE CONF
And it uses Let's say they're 11 byte values.
So it it uses a megabyte 1000 values.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, megabyte, no kilobytes.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Uses a kilobyte of memory to do that.
And then I'm like, OK, give me a million of
NOTE CONF
those, and it uses a megabyte and they say, OK,
give me a billion and it uses a gigabyte And
NOTE CONF
then I say, Give me 1000 billion and he goes,
Uh, no, I don't have enough memory right now.
NOTE CONF
Once I get to 1000 billion elements in my list,
I just can't do it.
NOTE CONF
There's just not enough memory in my computer, no matter
what I do.
NOTE CONF
And so I'd have to re architect that whole application
to do it in chunks, blah, blah, blah.
NOTE CONF
One of the advantages of a lazy limbs like has,
is that it doesn't matter how big the data structure
NOTE CONF
is.
Hasco won't try to load it into memory all at
NOTE CONF
once.
It'll only load in the bits that it needs.
NOTE CONF
So what we're gonna do here?
I was trying to think of something that's slow, but
NOTE CONF
I can't think of something that slow, so we'll just
double every element again.
NOTE CONF
So before we were doubling every element on the list
from 1 to 10, so if I double every element
NOTE CONF
on the list from 1 to 100 it does it
very quickly.
NOTE CONF
If I do 1000 does that relatively quickly, too.
100,000.
NOTE CONF
Ok, it's OK with that taking a while, but it
got there.
NOTE CONF
Um but this here is the list of one to
infinity, OK?
NOTE CONF
And obviously that's a data structure that's far too big
for my computer, but high school doesn't care it.
NOTE CONF
Lazy evaluation is a trick inside the machinery.
That means it can just look at the number that
NOTE CONF
it cares about right now.
There's gonna be another number later, but it doesn't have
NOTE CONF
to worry about what it is.
It does not try to load the infinitely long list
NOTE CONF
into memory.
And as far as I know, this will run forever.
NOTE CONF
This is not some trick where it eventually runs out
of memory and stops.
NOTE CONF
Um, it genuinely is a trick to deal with infinity.
And so our school kind of invented that not invented
NOTE CONF
that, but popularised that, um, and other languages now have
well list pater.
NOTE CONF
Other languages now have that, because it's not something you
can emulate in other ways.
NOTE CONF
So when you see Inka something like laziness, what's another
language that I know recently is added laziness.
NOTE CONF
Um anyway, so new languages tend to have the ability
to say that this value should be lazily evaluated instead
NOTE CONF
of the alternative, which is strictly evaluated exactly, because it's
a feature that really can't be emulated in other ways.
NOTE CONF
I'm pretty sure there's a P, but for laziness and
po like a cool Um, anyway, so that was it,
NOTE CONF
that well, then they the The book also goes into
the discussion with Wadler, which I think is interesting.
NOTE CONF
Um, definitely interesting.
Ah, they compare it to Spock, which is fine, because
NOTE CONF
it's super logical.
Uh, the comparison this box is good because he's logical
NOTE CONF
and he's always right.
You should just listen to him from the start, but
NOTE CONF
he can be difficult to deal with.
Same with Haskell.
NOTE CONF
You're like, God damn it, you're annoying me, Haskell.
And then by the end of the episode, you're like,
NOTE CONF
Ah, Haskell was right.
Um, yeah, So you ask What about the history?
NOTE CONF
And I I'm obviously not gonna disagree with anything that
Wadler says about his own language.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I think it's it's interesting enough.
Alright, that's it.
NOTE CONF
On how school do we have any questions?
Anyone wants to ask any others left over from before?
NOTE CONF
Even But yeah, yeah, but That's probably Firefox.
Yeah, I know.
NOTE CONF
Duck is up.
It's in D, and we can't tell because it D
NOTE CONF
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
NOTE CONF
No, I don't have to say, you know, just get
warm.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, low average.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
I mean, that's actually pretty quiet.
Realistically building up the movie.
NOTE CONF
It's got to one gig, so it must be anyway,
dude.
NOTE CONF
OK, so from here on in, we are.
I mean, you're getting your head around this topic, which
NOTE CONF
is, as you saw pretty chunky.
Um, but again, like with all of them, if you
NOTE CONF
can get the concept right and the picture right, then
you're good.
NOTE CONF
So a reminder.
You know, we we're doing fancy tree traversal.
NOTE CONF
We recognised a strange corner in the language.
We explored a few different ways to solve it.
NOTE CONF
And we settled on an extra data structure attached to
our tree that the static analysis phase communicates to the
NOTE CONF
interpreter That helps the interpreter avoid the error.
OK, And I think as you're reading through the code
NOTE CONF
knowing that that's where you're going helps a lot.
That's one thing.
NOTE CONF
I think that you're welcome to give me feedback now
And a reminder.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
First time I run the course.
NOTE CONF
So feedback.
Very much, especially pedagogical feedback.
NOTE CONF
You know which concept got me lost?
Which thing helped me most in my learning.
NOTE CONF
What do I wish you'd done that you hadn't done?
Those kinds of things are super useful.
NOTE CONF
Yes, we know that nothing was marked on time.
We already know that one.
NOTE CONF
You're welcome to tell us that, but yeah, we do
already know that.
NOTE CONF
Um it will be helpful for next year, but one
thing I think is having some of these diagrams and
NOTE CONF
explanations ready for you before you read the text.
Um, rather than trying to do them after the text
NOTE CONF
might be beneficial.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
Ok.
Thank you, everybody.
NOTE CONF
Uh, yes.
So revision from here on in to workshop class this
NOTE CONF
week.
And then Week 13 is revision practise exam coming soon
NOTE CONF
and marks for.
So some of you will have gotten your marks for
NOTE CONF
the distinction exam from last time.
Some of you haven't yet.
NOTE CONF
They're all gonna be done in the next 24 hours.
They're almost finished.
NOTE CONF
There's just another 15 or 20 students who've got one
more that needs grading.
NOTE CONF
So you will see your grade to know whether you
need to sit the last distinction exam.
NOTE CONF
And you will get your assignment two in time to
know whether you want to sit the last distinction exam
NOTE CONF
as well.
OK, especially because your distinction exams all the way at
NOTE CONF
the end of the holiday period.
Right?
NOTE CONF
And some people might just want to go home.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Thanks, everyone alright?
It works well.
NOTE CONF
Not doing objects in classes creates a decent end point
this week.
NOTE CONF
I'm happy with that.
I will, um
NOTE CONF